as a horrendously racist thing to say
but
I am British and we did invent racism so
you are welcome yeah well I mean like
what when you guys were little what did
you want to be
an astronaut [__] yeah what did you want
to be
a lawyer I'm gonna guess that one of you
achieved your dream
wow
so where did it all go wrong for you not
being an astronaut what was your first
were you ever really that committed
no my sister brought up a
couple fires your system brought up
fires this is incredibly tangential but
that well I'm sure we'll bring it back
around
yeah no she was like a fire's kitchen
really easy on uh in space and that was
enough to like fires catch on really
easy in space
I want to know what your sister does
she's serving 25 to life
and that's why you guys are together
right she was she actually got her off
the death penalty
wow okay so you wanted to be an
astronaut but now you are a teacher a
teacher oh cool and so you spent most of
your time telling the kids to follow
their dreams while not actually
following your own
what um
and then what type of law do you do
bankruptcy oh wow so you get rich off
other people's poverty this is Dreadful
yeah so your sister's in the Asylum you
make people go there I mean who the
people who are sat next to you are you
happy you're sat next to these what
what's your professions
why did you look at him
am I allowed to say my real job or do I
use the fake one
no job oh wow so you must have a [__]
great job if you're yeah what's your job
she's just handing over the card now
like in case it all goes tits up I can
so you're I mean I [__] should may I
touch your champagne [__] champagne a
comedy show and you've drank through it
this is absolutely fantastic this is the
most high class evening ever you've got
a British man and then
there's so much stuff I was about to
look at the check and see oh what tip
did he leave how's this guy so you're a
oh you left the tip oh that's nice there
you go thank you wow a banker yeah
[__] cool what's your name Banker
pardon Eduardo
I don't think your money's just from
banking Eduardo I
think Eduardo might might be a banker
for
for a very specific group of people
um
as a horrendously racist thing to say
but
I am British and we did invent racism so
you are welcome yeah don't get upset you
guys perfected it but we did
okay
and then Eduardo's lady what's your name
patty patty [__] that's I don't think
there's anywhere else in the world where
there is an Eduardo and a Patty I don't
think
so Patty the kept lady Eduardo the uh
the banker for a cartel uh our
bankruptcy lawyer and our teacher who
wanted to be an astronaut well this is a
tremendous combination it's it's
brilliant well what I would like to do
is kind of I don't want to forget this
in this moment we've had time I want to
commemorate it I do that through the
medium of hardcore gangster rap so uh DJ
if you do me a favor drop a beat this is
a this is a freestyle that's a wrap made
up on the spot based entirely on these
lovely four people uh it's gonna be
delightful don't worry it's not gonna be
anywhere near as atrociously [__] as you
expected to be
speaking to the kids you can reach them
standing in the classroom Blackboard the
teacher he sees the reprobates on the
back row he says don't worry bro I'm
gonna let you know you can reach for the
stars I thought when I was your rage I
could be an astronaut I caught the bug
saw them walking on the moon I know you
weren't born in the 60s but assume you
were watching all the TVs all the
shuttle launches sat there Sunday
morning sitting on your haunches one day
unless my life unravels won't be in the
classroom I'll be a Cape Canaveral
launching off yes in the air out the
atmosphere I'll be like come on NASA but
sadly you chose to teach dumb children
didn't join the Air Force it's a thrill
thing the lady sat there to your right
walking in and you like all my finances
[__] don't worry she saw you she can
help you out she's a nice bankruptcy
lawyer she'll make sure you don't have
to pay your debts just liquidate all of
your assets and then hide them away
that's the plan put them in the offshore
bank account came and who knows about
that Eduardo making sure we keep some
taxes so low no need to pay it legally
he could buy all of your property see
he's got so much cash he loves to spray
champagne what brand does he prefer my
way keep it on hand with the shamdunk
got his lady on his lap yes he wants one
she's the cat lady you a party coming
with Eduardo yo my name's Patty you said
that my name is reminiscent of beef
don't worry Chris Eduardo make sure you
won't leave he calls up his mates they
arrive in the Suburban they come in
where are they from you're preferring
they're like don't worry Eduardo go well
we kill that British rapper we're from
the cartel so fun the best by far he's
the banker for the drug lord escobarrod
or anyone like that really don't look at
his face when you walk right past he'll
see you he'll send them there to your
houses that's the thing oh my gosh so
wowzers we finished the rap there and I
admire it's just like your sister cause
I [__] spit fire
foreign